[Musik]
das liebe vieh zu
polarlichter machen christoph sie ist
glücklich
um sie zu sehen reist er ihnen jeden
winter nach das gleich mehrmals nicht
selten vergeblich den mann sind sie da
mal nicht so windig noch nicht so
schnell aber nur teile von damals schon
mal gut
also dem urteil ich römer umso größer
ist als der atmosphäre atom oder molekül
darf und das sah flüchtete
[Musik]
der meteor mann und seine total
verrückte liebe für polarlichter davon
handelt dieser film
[Musik]
im norwegischen irgendwo bei trance drei
breiten gerade über den polarkreis vom
flieger sofort ins auto
so macht er das immer wenn ihnen das
jagdfieber gepackt sein riecher für
polarlichter lästigen seiten im stich
falls sie tatsächlich auftauchen dann
draußen am erdboden darauf würde er
wetten
ja da war ich super perfekt
er bemüht sich um gelassenheit aber
innerlich strömt das adrenalin siegrist
challenge ist immer dieselbe
er will das perfekte foto tatsächlich
das spektakel land trosses nachthimmel
hat bereits begonnen
ja ich gesehen wenn wir uns blenden und
aber ganz recht deutlich
[Musik]
mal für mal drückt siegrist den auslöser
es ist der wahnsinn
gerade wenn wir unter sehr schmutzig
sowie für den man natürlich verlieren
aber es konnte aber im moment haben
einfach mehr fahrten und nochmal haare
stadt und und stühle und lugt was bewegt
was formal gewohnt deinem reinkommt der
schuldigen es ist relativ klar jaschin
[Musik]
da
es ist unfassbar schön selbst für
siegrist der das alles schon so oft
gesehen hat und die lightshow liebe
norwegens nachthimmel ist noch lange
nicht zu ende
[Musik]
dem himmel ist christoph sigrist ja auch
sonst immer ein wenig näher als wir
anderen der nette mann vom video doch
wer kennt die nicht seit bald 20 jahren
präsentiert siegrist seine prognosen
live am bildschirm
hunderttausende schauen hören ihm zu
doch auch nach all den jahren schüttelt
er seine moderationen nicht einfach
locker aus dem ärmel
der ansprechend und es möglichst perfekt
machen formuliert ich möglichst kurz
machen und dass ich meine
geschwindigkeit moderator dann
wettermoderators billigen der
bundeseinheitlich grauen der rote truhen
rückt am nachmittag christoph meckel
nicht dass er die kamera schaut
aber bei christoph sigrist stehen die
fakten über den großen auftritt genauso
präsentierte auch sein wetter kompetent
und stets mit leiser zurückhaltung
siegrist ist kein showman und will auch
keiner sein seinen job auf dem dach
liegt er immer noch wie am ersten tag
es gibt nur etwas was er noch lieber
täte er es mit eigenen augen sieht kann
diesen traum verstehen die magie der
tanzende lichter trifft mitten ins herz
und seele sind stattfindet also ich weiß
jetzt was macht habe ich weiß nicht
warum es jetzt zu seiner bürger geht ums
andere mal gibt es nur so eine
sonderlinie wenn das es dir der herr der
strahler was geht und wenn das ist die
sanfte form angeht da eine klinik wie
das funktioniert das tut mir einfach
dass das passiert
die formenvielfalt ist der wissenschaft
bis heute ein rätsel
doch wie polarlichter entstehen wusste
man schon vor weit über 100 jahren
tromsö am nächsten morgen die
nördlichste universitätsstadt der welt
ist die eigentliche wiege der polarlicht
forschung siegrist will uns zeigen womit
der norweger dem phänomen auf die
schliche kam christian entwickelt dass
rtl hätte das kind theater und das
klinikum metallkugel dänische magnet und
da links verstarb dort schickt für
elektronen in die richtig kohle und roma
hat sich das war kommen also war kommt
es teilweise sehr wenig teil über darin
sie und wenn jetzt auf der sonnenwind
knopfdruck der euro aber die elektron
aus dem staub dort links und wahrte mit
dem magnetfeld zu der trawler gleitet
und da gibt es genau der kreis um die
beiden nord und südpol genau wie es
funktioniert und die big band etwas als
erste entdeckt oder einigkeit so
funktioniert's polarlicht natürlich
damals ist belastet wurde - vom zoo über
metadaten können meister damals und ich
erst jahrzehnte später bestätigt worden
[Musik]
so ist es endlich richtig hält die stadt
ist eine beauty bei unserem besuch im
frühen winter schafft es die sonne
selbst mittags nur noch knapp über dem
horizont
doch sonnenstand und wetter kümmern ihn
verein mal garnicht polarlicht jäger
siegrist prüft seine bilder von letzter
nacht wenn er könnte wäre noch viel
öfter hier weil das nicht geht hatte
sich etwas einfallen lassen
[Musik]
damit er das naturphänomen jederzeit auf
der einen computer beobachten kann hat
sich siegrist einen polarlicht allein
gebaut auf dem dach des mid ju büros
steht der prototyp diese test kamera
erwischt in der schweiz natürlich keine
polarlichter aber sie hilft das von a
bis z selbst entwickelte system zu
optimieren
was trauen sie dem richtigen oslo aus
den losen die polarlicht alarm marke sie
christ braucht einen vollservice die
idee für dieses verrückte teil reifte
über jahre das problem dass man das will
wenn sich wenn hatte ursprünglich eine
vielmehr als umwelt reagiert dass wir
ein starkes und sms gehabt aber es hat
das wetter oder der wunsch als erste mp
tec tisch und scratches gar nicht und
dann im kontakt mit der kamera machen
habe das bild macht und analysiert und
tal macht das ist jetzt das
da es funktioniert ganz einfach dass die
kamera speziell ist objektiv so
genanntes fischer auch objektiv der
ganze himmel hätte denn etwas computer
lieber kamera stören da macht das bild
auch paar minuten unterschied so
versöhnlich
der server analysiert und wenn es mal
nicht durch hitzealarm
es gab zwar einige rückschläge doch
einer wie sie christ gibt nie auf
inzwischen funktioniert das kamerasystem
prächtig wann immer er will kann er von
jedem ort der welt aus abdecken was sich
am nächtlichen himmel abspielt
fortan ließ nacht vom westhorizont
geister über den horizont über wunderbar
grün und sehr von der form her
interessant
siegrist erfindung ist ein echter
knaller findet sein schiff brennt mir
dass irgendein ist sowie klarheit
verzählt und dann harry müssen auch lose
was er freilich weit will das hätte so
ganz bescheiden auf den ort braucht
inhalten des projektes entwickelt mit
kameras und polarlicht und dann habe ich
dennoch überzeugt so denn ich mir die
frage vor dem projekt überhaupt klar
wurde aber das zeichnete in der user
macht kein großes aufheben sven regener
gemacht sondern zeigt das einfach und
man merkt er später seine geschickt
die test kamera funktioniert wieder
einwandfrei fiel nur noch ein kleines
tuning was wirklich ist da die statur
will ja probleme schon darauf und wenn
ihr stange hocken sie hoffentlich nur
theorie form aber ich glaube das ist
fertig zum thema gerade würde ich sagen
mittlerweile neun kameras erst gebaut
und sie am polarkreis entlang
aufgestellt vier davon stehen auf island
drei weitere kameras installierte er in
finnisch lappland und noch einmal zwei
stehen in norwegen eine davon nicht
allzu weit von tromsö
[Musik]
wir fahren auf der nachbarinsel klar in
richtung norden sieges will uns seine
neueste kamera zeigen
er hat sie erst vor ein paar monaten
hier oben installiert auf einem
privatgrundstück draußen in risiko ein
gutes geschäft denn tromsö ist derzeit
ein absoluter hotspot für polarlicht
jäger mit japan ist auch speziell die
befragten frauen junge paar lieder
untergrund ist die japaner sagen wenn
man es kennt unter dem polarlicht zückte
der nächsten serie skins sind die fahrt
durch die nordische märchenlandschaft
ist leider schon zu ende
sie hätte noch ewig dauern dürfen aber
christoph siegrist hat ja eine
verabredung
[Applaus]
wie geht es dir super ihr seid schon da
wie schön ich möchte mal schaun bitte
kamera alles okay ist und ich habe mir
noch gar nicht zurecht gemacht also dann
gehe ich schon mal okay nach nur ein
polarlicht alarm steht nicht irgendwo im
garten die kamera hängt am hausdach ein
perfekter standort in einer perfekten
gegend dunkel war das russische paar
wenige johanna und frauen gesetzte
richtung norden und westen
als variante schlechter ich fand es ist
optimal svens polarlicht otto reutter
und das hätten das gut
das komplexe system natürlich nicht so
einfach zum händler deshalb nicht
einfach konflikt wenn der pc fischen dbv
winterthur und die wir können sie eine
schöne bilder machten
wie lange es jetzt darum mit
durchschleppen ist es anders kam also
besitzt sowie tisch ist das sicher jahre
insgesamt aber dass seine step by step
oder mitfahrer gemacht wird erklärt was
man muss mache das man muss heute war
das was auch hatte das leben es mitte
zieht es weg findet die kamera großartig
aber sie hält es wie die meisten
einheimischen am polarkreis
für uns ist es etwas alltägliches wir
nehmen es nicht mehr wahr
die leute gehen raus und zehn es gar
nicht wenn sie wirklich schön sind so
wie gestern dann sagen sie hast du die
nordlichter gesehen und dann antworten
sie ja oder nein
es ist halt einfach da ein teil von und
auch dass es leute gibt die gemerkt
haben dass es morgen ein naturphänomen
liegt das so unglaublich ist dass wir es
mit anderen menschen aus der ganzen welt
teilen können wirklich toll
ziemlich cool finde trine auch als sie
von unserer fährt das siegel ist der
mann vom schweizer fernsehen ist das ist
großartig ich fass es nicht
es soll bescheiden und scheu er hat mir
das nicht gesagt er sagte so nun ich
kenne ja nicht darum die organisation
dieser kameras und dann hätten wir sie
hier auf und jetzt erzählen so dass er
eigentlich ein star ist bei euch ich bin
beeindruckt
ich mach da nur die wettervorhersage ja
manchmal ist es nicht nur also ich gehe
heim und da kann trine googeln so viel
sie will wirklich brisantes wird sie
nicht über ihn finden
keine skandale keine schlagzeilen
doch es gab einmal eine also die sendung
verpasste weil er es zu spät aufs dach
schaffte
sie ist hat gerne seine ruhe sucht die
natur wie hier im appenzellerland
ja das ist natürlich also der kassette
ganz tagen oder in den computer setzen
programm jeder und da theoretisch damit
befassen
verschiedene monika hauser und das ist
wirklich das mache sie egal verschiedene
der witz ist dadurch viel mehr ist wie
die schneeflocke da sie das machen
[Musik]
die privatsphäre ist siegrist eilig
fragen zu seiner freundin lager nicht
beantworten
eine homestory völlig ausgeschlossen
dabei würde das doch eigentlich viele
interessieren
es ist nicht nötig für den job oder das
ist wichtig ist das ihr gutes op und
nick dass sie als möglich ein sofa hat
privat bleibt privat
das heißt der begriff aber das ist
natürlich ein privat sie und wenn jetzt
der häftlinge china würde meine prognose
presskraft besser
[Musik]
sagt's und schweigt mehr gibt es nicht
für christoph siegrist ist das thema
privatleben damit erledigt
da ist er konsequent wie in allem was er
anpackt
zurück im norden norwegens
heute will sie ist hoch hinaus sein plan
für die nacht er will polarlicht und
statt auf einem bild dafür muss er auf
toms hausberg den viel heißen sie christ
studiert den klaren himmel genau
gemäss seinen meteo daten sollen in der
nacht dicke wolken über trance zu ziehen
doch bauchgefühl und erfahrung sagen ihm
etwas anderes
es sind ja nicht nur die drohenden
wolken so wunderschön ist hier oben ist
es ist bitterkalt dazu fähigen heftige
windböen über den viel reisen also ein
spaziergang wird das heute nacht nicht
es ist erst 14 uhr
doch die sonne ist längst wieder unter
dem horizont verschwunden
die perfekte vorbereitung ist für einen
polarlicht jäger entscheidend damit es
wenn es zählt doch wirklich aufgeht
und genau diesen ausschnitt will er
später im bild haben brauchst du das
portal ist vordergrund dass wir da noch
lustig heiduck wäre wird starten
irgendwo das advents polarlichter plan
in stuttgart wo kurz für alle anderen
ist sie innerlich kamera sei dank wir
können an der wärme auf das spektakel
warten
es ist kurz nach 17 uhr und endlich
dunkel
das alarmsystem schickt die neuesten
daten früher den aufwand aber dass gutes
passt umso unerwähnt dass der rechte
schwank rege tätigkeit des langsam unter
uns die lichter von tromsö über uns der
klaren nachthimmel
aber kein polarlicht
bottrop
ob netz bücher kleben stress gar ja ist
natürlich ein scharfmacher ist lässt er
alles parat denn ruhig jetzt man sich
wieder schaut die stelle überhaupt nicht
vorstellen es ist dunkel europa rückt
aber das ist eben auch verpflichtungen
und berichtet diese relativ schwache
letzte das man sich ganz zum kurs geht
das jetzt schon vergleichbar licht ist
100 mal schwächer als der vollmond zum
beispiel und plötzlich von einer sekunde
auf die andere sind sie da
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja es kribbelt natürlich so also jetzt
vor die am anfang bin ich nervös krieg
frauen erschweren dürfte das auf die
frage ist ist sie aber das stück besitzt
es kommt vor ort der langsam über
wichtig weststadt dabei
[Musik]
das panorama gemacht weil er zwar seine
sweeting tricks objektiver so viel vom
himmel
aber es eigentlich nicht platzt bald ist
es groß thompson und polarlicht auf
einem foto
er hat es tatsächlich geschafft physik
ist ein stiller moment des glücks die
tiefe freude ist ihm ins gesicht
geschrieben
wir haben sich vorgestellt dass es über
die statistik und wenn man auch dass ich
das bild manfred stadt mit dass das war
gar nichts darüber dass es so kommt
polarlichter auf viel lesen
schöner geht nicht also anders schreibt
mir keine wechselfehler weihnachten
leichter macht glücklich ja klar
extrem glücklich